[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAAD ALI: Hi, my
name is Saad Ali.
I'm a software
engineer at Google,
and I work on the storage
stack of Kubernetes.
Today, I'm going to talk
about storage classes
and dynamic volume
provisioning--
a new feature in Kubernetes.
First I'll introduce
these concepts,
and then my colleague Matt will
walk you through a demo on GKE.
Let's start by identifying
what problems Kubernetes volume
plug-ins are aiming to solve.
First is that the basic unit
of scheduling in Kubernetes
is a pod, which is a
collection of containers.
Containers do not share
their file system,
but pods are composed of
possibly multiple containers.
This could be, for example, a
reader and a writer container
that work together.
So it would be really nice
to be able to share files
between containers in a pod.
Second problem is that
containers are ephemeral,
and the files inside
a container are also
ephemeral-- meaning
they're deleted when
the container is terminated.
This means if a container
crashes or the machine
is restarted, you lose your
data inside the container.
If you're trying to
run a stateful service,
having your data
disappear in a nonstarter.
This is where Kubernetes
Volumes come in.
At its core, a volume
is just a directory--
possibly with some data
pre-populated in it--
which is accessible to all
the containers in a pod.
How that directory
comes to be, the medium
that backs it, its content, what
happens to it after the pod is
terminated, are all determined
by the particular volume type
used.
OK, let's take a look
at the volume plug-ins
we have in Kubernetes.
The plug-ins can be categorized
into a few large buckets.
One class of volumes
is persistent network
attached storage.
These are volumes that outlived
the lifecycle of a pod.
This could be anything from
manifests shared to a Cloud
provider virtual disk.
The lifecycle of
these volumes is
independent from the lifecycle
of an individual pod.
When a pod referencing one
of these volumes is created,
the storage is
automatically made available
inside the container
of that pod.
The volumes are automatically
attached and mounted.
When the pod is
terminated, the volume
is automatically unmounted
and detached if needed.
But the data on the
volume remains intact--
and that's the key.
The data is persisted.
If another pod comes
along and references
the same instance of
the volume, they'll
see the same exact data.
Another class of
volumes is ephemeral.
These volumes are created when
a pod starts, and is deleted
when a pod is terminated.
Empty dir is the
prime example here.
It is shared scratch
space between pods.
Kubernetes creates
an empty directory
on the underlying node machine,
either from the local disk
or from an in-memory tmpfs.
And it mounts the directory into
all the containers in the pod.
Then when the
containers start, they
have some shared scratch
space between them.
When the pod is terminated,
the directory and its content
is deleted.
Secret, ConfigMap
and DownwardAPI
are concepts in
the Kubernetes API.
They are mechanisms for sharing
configuration and cluster
information with applications.
One of the core
principles of Kubernetes
is to meet the users
where they are.
This means that instead
of requiring applications
to talk to Kubernetes
API, we try
to make the data
available in the form
that applications already
know how to consume.
So while existing
apps won't necessarily
know how to talk
to Kubernetes API,
they can probably already
read config info from a file.
And so Secret, ConfigMap,
and DownwardAPI volumes
are a mechanism for exposing
these Kubernetes API
objects as files inside
the container of a pod.
These volumes are essentially
an empty dir under the cover,
but pre-populated with the
contents of the Kubernetes API
server on creation,
instead of being empty.
Now let's take a
look at an example.
Here we have a pod.
A pod is a basic unit of
scheduling in Kubernetes.
Pods are a collection of
containers, or in this case,
a single BusyBox container
that doesn't really do anything
but sleep on startup.
This pod directly references
a Google Compute Engine
persistent disk volume
called Panda Disk for use
by all the containers
in this pod.
The volume is assumed
to already exist.
The pod also defines
where inside the container
the volume should be mounted.
Now, this example
seems pretty trivial,
but the real beauty is what
happens under the covers.
When the pod is created,
Kubernetes automatically
calls out to the
Google Cloud API
and attaches the
specified PD to the node
that the pod is scheduled to.
It then formats the disk,
if needed, and mounts it
into the container
that makes up the pod.
When the pod is moved
to another node,
Kubernetes automatically calls
out to the Google Cloud API,
detaches the persistent
disk from the first node,
and attaches it to
the second node.
And repeats the
same song and dance
to mount the volume
inside the new instance
of the pod on the second node.
All of this happens
invisibly for the user,
and makes it so
that they don't have
to worry about what machine the
workload actually landed on.
Kubernetes just
takes care of it.
But there is something
not quite right here.
Let's take a step back and
talk about a really nice design
principle that many of you
are probably familiar with--
the separation of concerns.
It says that the components
managing distinct functionality
should, themselves,
be separated.
This enables you to isolate,
revise, and test components
independently.
It allows you to make your
larger system modular,
so that you can swap out
pieces without affecting
other components.
And Kubernetes
does exactly that.
It takes functionality
that used to be
smeared across various layers
and handles them explicitly.
It decouples the
application layer
from the cluster resources
required to run applications.
That means, as an
application developer,
you don't have to worry
about the implementation
details of the cluster your
workload is running on anymore.
You don't have to worry about
which particular machine
your app is running on.
You don't have to worry about
whether that machine has
enough ports.
You don't have to worry
about what other apps are
running on that machine.
Kubernetes abstracts
all of that away
and exposes an API that
allows you, as an application
developer, to simply describe
the service you want to run,
along with the resources
it will require.
Kubernetes takes
care of the rest.
If you think about it,
Kubernetes in this regard
is very much like an
operating system for clusters.
Think back to the
earliest days of computers
when there were no
operating systems,
and every program needed a
full hardware spec to perform
even the basic tasks.
Distributed system
application development
has been in this
stage for a long time.
And now, Kubernetes finally
introduces an abstraction layer
that hides the implementation
details and complexity
of cluster implementation.
The real beauty of
an abstraction layer
is that it allows
you to swap out
the components underneath it.
It enables portability.
You can run Kubernetes on a
lot of different environments.
Everything from Cloud providers
like Google Cloud, AWS,
and even on Bare Metal
on-prem clusters-- all
with a consistent API.
This decoupling of
application from cluster
allows applications to be
Cloud provider agnostic,
and not worry about
network model, load
balancing, persistent storage.
This is great for you as
an application developer,
because it allows you to write
your applications, services,
deployment descriptions-- once.
And have them work regardless
of the underlying cluster.
It helps avoid vendor lock-in.
Now that's a really
pretty picture
I just painted, but for those
of you who are paying attention,
you probably are asking--
didn't your pod definition
specify exactly the type
of volume to use for
persistent storage?
You specified a GCEPD
with the name Panda Disk.
Now, if you take
that pod description
and drop it on a
non-GCE cluster,
it's not going to work, right?
You would be absolutely right.
This is where the Kubernetes
concept of PersistentVolume
and PersistentVolumeClaim
objects comes into the picture.
PersistentVolume and
PersistentVolumeClaim objects
enable an abstraction between
the consumption of storage
and the implementation
of storage.
The PersistentVolume
object is a representation
of a piece of storage
available on the cluster,
and the PersistentVolumeClaim
is a request
for storage on behalf
of an application trying
to run on the cluster.
Let's take a look at an example.
First, we have to
expose the storage
available for the
application to use.
We do this by creating
a PV object to represent
each piece of storage
available for applications
to use on the cluster.
Each PersistentVolume
object contains
a description of the
storage it exposes,
and connection information.
Normally, cluster or
storage administrators
create these PV objects--
not application developers.
Once these PV
objects are created,
they're available for use.
Now if an application
developer wants
to use storage on this
cluster, they must first
create a request for storage.
This is done by
creating a PVC object.
In the PVC object, you define
the minimum requirements
for the storage you need--
the minimum disk capacity and
the required access modes.
When the PVC object is created,
Kubernetes takes the request
and matches it with an
available, unbound PV.
In this case, it finds one of
the PV objects that we created
earlier-- a 100 gigabyte GCEPD--
is available and unbound.
So it binds this
to the request--
the PVC.
Now this claim can be used
by the application developer.
Let's go back to the pod
definition we used earlier.
In order to use the
storage, you can now
reference the claim for
storage, instead of directly
referencing a specific volume.
The beauty of this is that our
pod definition is now portable.
The request for
storage resources
is decoupled from the specific
implementation of storage.
We can take this pod definition
and drop it on any Kubernetes
cluster, and as long as
there is available storage,
it will just work.
And even if you're running
only on a single cluster,
it means that your cluster
administrator can completely
swap out or modify the storage
system in your cluster,
but your pod definitions
won't need to change.
So the PersistentVolume
and PersistentVolumeClaim
abstraction is really nice
for giving us portability.
But you probably noticed that
there was a step in there
that was a little cumbersome--
having a cluster admin
or storage provider
pre-provision all the
volumes available for use
in the cluster.
This is where dynamic volume
provisioning comes in.
This is a feature that
is unique to Kubernetes.
The idea is that when a request
for storage is created--
when a PVC is created--
the cluster automatically
creates a new piece of storage
to fulfill that request.
This makes a lot of sense in
Cloud environments like GKE,
where an API call can
provision new storage
within a matter of seconds.
But even for non-Cloud
storage systems like NFS,
you could write a
provisioner that
maybe triggers the creation
of a new share on demand.
To use dynamic provisioning,
the cluster storage admin
must first enable it.
They do this by creating one
or more StorageClass objects.
The StorageClass
object specifies
the volume plugin to
use for provisioning,
and the parameters to
pass to that plug-in.
The parameters for
the storage class
are a blob of key value pairs--
that the provisioner
presumably understands.
In this case, the
first storage class
says-- when executed, call
the GCEPD volume plug-in,
and pass in parameters to
create a standard spinning disk.
The second storage class pretty
much says the same thing,
but instead passes in parameters
to create an SSD-GCEPD.
The parameters are defined
by the volume plug-in
and set by cluster
admins, and are
opaque to Kubernetes otherwise.
What's really neat about that
is that since the parameter
list is a blob that is passed
through to the provisioner,
Kubernetes doesn't have
to get into the business
of enumerating every possible
parameter for every storage
system in its API.
Plug-ins expose an arbitrary set
of knobs for disk provisioning,
and cluster admins can
tweak them at will.
Cluster admins can define
multiple storage classes
to expose different tiers, or
groupings, of storage cluster
users.
And users don't have to
worry about the details.
So in this case,
the cluster admin
exposed what they called
fast and slow storage.
And application
developers don't have
to worry about the
details of what
that means under the
covers, they just
pick from the storage classes
that are exposed to them.
To use storage-- just as
before-- the application
developer creates a
PersistentVolumeClaim
object to request storage.
In the PersistentVolumeClaim
object,
they now specify the
storage class to use.
In Kubernetes 1.6, this is a
new field in the PVC object.
In earlier versions, this was
an annotation on the PVC object.
When a PVC object with a
storage class is created,
instead of binding to an
existing available PV,
Kubernetes calls the
provisioner defined
in the specified storage
class to create a new volume.
In this case, it calls
the GCEPD plug-in,
which calls out to
the GCE API to create
a new SSD-backed GCEPD.
Once the new storage
volume is provisioned,
Kubernetes automatically
creates a PV object
to represent the new
storage, and then binds it
to the user's
PersistentVolumeClaim.
It's important to note that
dynamically-provisioned volumes
are created with a
delete retention policy.
That means once
the PVC is deleted,
the dynamically-provisioned
volume
will automatically be deleted.
If you don't want
that to happen,
you should update the
PersistentVolume object
after it is
automatically created,
and change the retention policy
to Retain instead of Delete.
Once the new volume is
created and bound to the PVC,
users can reference the PVC
in their pod definitions
exactly the same way.
Something else to keep in
mind is that storage classes
can be marked as default.
Marking a storage
class as default
makes it so that even
a PVC without a
storage class specified
will trigger
provisioning, instead
of binding to an
existing pool of PVs.
This is a mechanism
for cluster admins
to force dynamic provisioning.
Also important to note
is that Kubernetes 1.6
will come with a storage
class pre-installed and set
as default for GKE and
other Cloud providers.
This is something
to pay attention
to if you've been using
Kubernetes for a while,
because it changes the default
behavior of PVC objects
on these Clouds.
It used to be that PVC objects
without storage classes
would bind to available
existing PV objects.
But on these Clouds,
with 1.6, because there
will be pre-installed
default storage class,
a PVC without a storage
class will still
trigger the creation
of a new volume.
If you want to
disable this behavior,
you'll have to modify
the storage class
and remove the
default annotation.
Now I'm going to hand it
over to Matt to demo this.
MATTHEW DELIO: Thank you, Saad.
My name is Matthew DeLio.
I'm a product manager
for Kubernetes and GKE,
and I work on
networking and storage.
Today I'm going to be doing
a couple of demos for you.
The first is a demo of how
to manually provision and use
a disk inside GKE.
In the second, we'll use the
dynamic provisioning feature
that Saad talked about earlier.
So let's jump right in.
I've already created a cluster.
It has three nodes in
it, and each one of them
has one virtual CPU.
I'm using version
1.53 of Kubernetes,
so it's going to use the
annotation that Saad mentioned
earlier, rather than the
built-in storage class things
that we introduced in 1.6.
So going back to
my terminal screen,
I'm going to run this demo.
And just to see that there
is no other disks inside GKE,
I'm going to run
this GCloud command.
And from here, we can see
that there's just three disks.
These correspond
to the three nodes
that I have in my cluster.
And now we're going to
check to make sure there
is no physical volumes--
PVs-- and there's also no PVCs--
Physical Volume Claims.
Next, I will use
GCloud to create
a new disk inside
Google Cloud Platform,
and I will call
it Manual Disk 1.
That's step number one.
Next, we're going to
make sure it exists.
So we're going to run
the GCloud command
to list the disks that we have.
And we can see that we
have our three node disks.
And now we also
have Manual Disk 1.
Next, we're going to add a
corresponding physical volume
to Kubernetes.
So I've just created
a simple YAML
file that lists the name
of the actual disk I
want to use-- that's the PV
name down at the bottom here.
And that says manual disk 1.
Then I can give it a name.
I'm going to call it
Manually Created PV.
I have a capacity that's
set to 10 gigabytes,
and I've set the reclaim
policy to be Retain.
So I'm going to load
that into Kubernetes.
So that's in now.
And now we're going to
make sure it exists.
So I'm running the
kubectl get pv.
And that'll list the
disks that we have,
and we can see that it exists.
We have 10 gigabytes available.
The reclaim policy is
what we expect it to be,
which is retain.
And it's four seconds old.
Now we're going to go ahead
and create a physical volume
claim by asking for 10
gigabytes of storage.
We're going to call it My PVC,
and we're going to go ahead now
and load that into Kubernetes.
So at this point, we should have
a PV, and we should have a PVC,
and the PV should
be bound to the PVC.
So we're going to
check that real quick.
I've listed both the PVs--
the physical volumes--
and the PVCs--
the physical volume claims.
Now in the first
couple of lines,
you see that we have a bound PV.
It's bound to-- has a
claim of Demos/MyPVC.
And the second last two
lines, we have My PVC,
and it's bound to
Manually Created PV.
The final step is to use this
physical volume claim in a pod.
And so here we are,
we've referenced
the claim name that's in
this line under volumes.
And we're going ahead
and creating a new pod.
It's called Sleepy pod.
It doesn't do much, it
just sleeps for 100 minutes
and then goes to sleep.
So we go ahead and created that.
It's going to take a few seconds
to warm up and actually create
the pod.
And so while we're
waiting, we're
just going to check on it.
Looks like it's running now.
So I'm going to go
ahead and show you
what happens when you want to
tear down one of these setups.
So the first thing you need
to do is delete the pod.
At this point, you still
have a PVC in a PV.
And those are still
bound to each other.
And while we're waiting
for that pod to delete--
it takes a few seconds
for the pod to delete.
But once it's done, we
should be able to see--
at this point our
pod is deleted.
Now we're going to go
ahead and delete the PVC,
and also delete the PV.
So as you can see--
I just checked to make sure
that there's no PV and PVC
resources.
And now we need to actually
delete the disk in Google Cloud
Platform.
So I ran the GCloud
command to do that.
So that's it.
There's four steps of manually
provisioning a physical volume
and using it in Kubernetes.
The first step is to
go ahead and create
the volume in Google Cloud.
The second step is to create
a PV object in Kubernetes.
Then you need to
create a PVC object--
a PhysicalVolumeClaim--
in Kubernetes.
And then you can
finally use it in a pod.
Next I'll show how we can use
dynamic volume provisioning
to make this process
a lot easier.
And so I'm going to go
ahead and start up my demo.
And just to show, again,
that there's nothing
going on behind the scenes,
I've got a list of all my disks.
We have-- again-- three nodes,
three disks corresponding
to those three nodes,
and no other disks
available in the system.
Next I'm going to
go ahead and show
that there's no storage
classes that we've already
loaded into the system.
As you can see, there's none.
And finally, we're
going to make sure
that there's no physical volumes
or physical volume claims that
exist in Kubernetes.
So we have a pretty
vanilla system right here.
We haven't done anything yet.
The first step is to
add storage classes.
And so, I've got
here is a YAML file.
It's very simple,
because I'm using 1.5.2--
which still is in beta.
But when it goes to
1.6, this will no longer
be a beta API object.
I'm going to create
this storage class.
Its type name is Fast.
Its type is SSD.
And we're going to use
the GCE provisioner, which
you can see is all listed
here in the YAML file.
So we'll go ahead and
load that into Kubernetes.
Next we're going to go ahead
and list the storage classes.
So you can see that we have
the Fast type of storage.
And we can see that
it's a GCEPD type.
Now we just have to add a PVC.
So this one's a little
bit different than what
we had when we were manually
provisioning our storage.
This one has an annotation.
Again, the annotation
will be different
when we switch to 1.6.
But right now we're on 1.5.
And I just have to add
the annotation to say--
I want this storage
class set to Fast.
And I say that I
want 10 gigabytes.
And once I create
this PVC, what it's
going to do-- it's
going to go ahead
and provision the storage
on Google Cloud Platform.
And it's going to create a
bind to that storage object.
So to see that, we can go
ahead and list the disks.
And you can see that we
have a new disk here.
It's at the very
top of the list.
It's a 10 gigabyte,
and its type is SSD--
just as we expected when we
created this storage class.
It's very simple to now use
the PVC in the pod.YAML file.
This is actually the
exact same YAML file
I used earlier in the
manually provisioned example.
So let's go ahead and
load that into Kubernetes.
At this point, the disk
has already been created,
and we just need to
start up the pod.
Great, so now it's running.
We'll go ahead and just
show the deletion path.
So now I want to delete the pod.
Again, I just delete
the pod as before.
It will take some
time for the pod
to actually shut
down and terminate.
Now the pod is shut down.
I'm going to go ahead and run
a GCloud compute disks list.
And this will show
us all the disks
that we still have
in our system.
As you can see
from here, we still
have a PVC-backed storage that
was dynamically provisioned.
And its size is still
10 gig, as we'd expect.
I'm going to go ahead
and delete the PVC.
When I do that, I
would expect the PV--
the actual backing
disk-- to be deleted.
If we go ahead and
check that, now we
can see that it's
actually deleted.
So there you have it.
To use dynamic
volume provisioning,
all you have to do is
create a storage class,
create a volume claim, and
then use the volume claim.
And so as you can see,
dynamics storage provisioning
makes it a lot easier.
We only had to allocate
a storage class type,
and we can use it everywhere.
That's it for the demo.
Thank you very much, and I'll
turn it back to Saad now.
SAAD ALI: Thank you,
Matt, for that demo.
So that's an overview of
dynamic provisioning and storage
classes and GKE--
a unique feature
in Kubernetes that
enables storage to be created
automatically when it's needed.
Thank you for joining us.
To get involved
or to learn more,
visit us at the storage SIG.
To try Container
Engine, use this code
for a free trial account.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
as